all right Zac Ephron you win starting
crunches tomorrow which I said every day
for the past month or so that guy did
not skip a day I'll tell you that hey
watch I made this mood so Baywatch is a
movie based on the show from the 90s as
for the show from the 90s Baywatch
existed was the number one show on TV
for a while it was a number-one show on
TV for a while because it was
pre-internet
and if teenagers wanted to see boobs
citizens out of Islam I mean didn't
actually see boobs everything was
covered but girls were always running on
the beach results Lum of the titties
were bouncing pretty good time for
junior high student Baywatch and in
living color I have fond memories of
just both on all the time so now in 2017
Dave made a film adaptation of Baywatch
starring the rock and Zac Efron and it's
ridiculous as you would think it is
which to the movie's credit is very
self-aware of then the bear wash TV show
would be like ooh there's crime we have
to investigate and why would we not call
the cops I never really thought about
that with the Baywatch TV show because
like I said I've one thing on my mind
and it was not the plot so when the
rocks like we need to investigate Zac
Efron's like or we could call the cops
it's a running joke in this movie that
actually does lame I say actually does
land because there are a lot of jokes in
this movie that absolutely [ __ ] do
not land oh my god to a painful degree
ever seen a one-liner where you're like
yeah that's not funny that's nothing
compared to a running gag that's just
not landing and it's taking about five
minutes your life to stop please but a
love of everything stop like there's
this chubby dorky dude in the movie who
may or may not have been in movies
before I don't really recognize him from
anything it pains me because I feel like
this is this big break and I'm about to
shred his character anything doing with
that dude suck why is he in the movie I
have no idea and the characters would
act one way one moment and then
completely different the next moment I
don't know if that's because of the
writing or the editing something was
edited a certain way so that was going
to be here and that was going to be here
and there was going to be a long stretch
in between but we just stitched it
together back to back so now it looks
like someone had one mindset one second
and another mindset the very next second
like Zac Efron he's the hot head he
doesn't play well with others he's not a
team player if he's supposed to be on
lookout while they're all trying to
snoop around this club but he's getting
drunk so one of the girls comes over to
him and she's like a little
the point in you let's be done look out
and I'm not mad I'm just disappointed
then it cuts over to the rock doing his
fangs back to him and now she she's all
smiling and they're flirting and I'm
like I why you got over that pretty
quickly that happens a few times this
movie is like what were there was there
a reshoot for this scene in this movie
you guys could afford ratio eights crazy
couldn't afford good CGI fire effects
there's a scene where the rock is in
this yacht that's on fire and fire is
everywhere he's in this flaming ass room
I have been next to campfires that have
been unbearably hot I've had to take a
few steps back they [ __ ] is all around
him fight he has this little plastic
floaty thing that Baywatch people have
lifeguards to have them it's a real
thing but this plastic thing has CGI
fire licking it it literally this thing
is in the fire like it's a marshmallow
being roasted
I put plastic in fire try it see what
happens any effect on that rochette when
I say nothing in this movie makes sense
I mean nothing in this movie actually
makes sense assume of this girl gets
good evidence on her phone video style
of these bad dudes doing bad dude things
and the dudes even admit everything
because you have to have them word vomit
a perfect confession when they don't
know the ring phone then they get a hold
of the phone they run and right in front
of the rocks do crushes the phones like
rocks useless now notice the video is
saved to the testee card like a micro SD
card it's probably fine Jen reminds me
of those movies where someone's
uploading or downloading something it
was like all the live above them to
shoot the monitor say ah shucks he
stopped us they didn't this is the
monitor or how about another scene when
the rock and Zac Efron peek through this
window and they see all these guys doing
all these bad things with drugs and the
porn drugs out no one takes a cell phone
video of that [ __ ] just duck under the
window like alright I'm just I'm gonna
record this displays regarding now and
maybe he lost his faith in phones that
cuz one got crushed with Zac Efron's
character there is actually a good
opportunity for a good character he's
this Olympic gold medal champion but
after the Olympics were over and that
was just he's not really a very sad
story with him it doesn't really get
explored guys in the end Baywatch was
garbage it's not good more than a few
occasions in this movie I can see
reaching into the realm of guilty
pleasure movie but in the end it doesn't
quite get there alcohol I'm going to
save this one
gonna say you're not going to remember
bay watching t-minus one day yeah I
already forgot all right guys you're not
going to see bay watches don't do that
to yourself so what is a movie based on
a TV show that you would like to see
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]